hey guys feat peppers here with candy
crush soda saga tips making a how-to
video for candy crush jelly saga in the
new game in the series which should be
coming out any day now and this is a
how-to on the level type of the puffers
level type crack the frosting to find
all the puffers so buffalos are just
made up creatures they're kind of like
worms with a I don't know bear head or
something like that so they're I can't
think of any actual you know real life
example that's you know what they are
but um they're like I said they are like
warmi they they're underneath the ice
they they're sort of like bear levels
but there's some major differences here
and we'll go over that but you can see
that you know the general idea is to
crack the grass all the glass that's
above them so their whole body is free
and then they'll fly away and you'll
collect them and we have a mint we have
a meter at the top that tells us we need
to collect three of them which are all
hid under the ice somewhere on this
board so we don't know where they're at
but it's similar to bears you can find
them you can so you can sort of faintly
see them there's one's head and this is
the big thing that you have to keep in
mind that makes them different is that
they actually move you can see his head
was here we exposed it and so he sort of
ran away so we saw one over this way
and we can just free him right there
definitely important to track where they
go this is an easy level it's got a lot
of moves for not a lot of ice so it's
not as vital on this one but like in
some of the higher levels you'll find
out that you know you have to know where
they're at and attack the place where
they're at because you don't have enough
moves to just randomly clear all the ice
and hope to find them so I was thinking
that might be one over here kind of
looks like it behind that yellow candy
yep and it's moving so now it's down
here so strategy wise
when you can't clear the spot where
they're at it still makes a lot of sense
to do what I'm going to do right here
which is I'm going to cut off the
connection so that it can't go anywhere
else so even though this one's exposed
since there's no connect connected ice
it can't crawl away like it has to stay
under the ice so it's stuck right there
until the end now until I can you know
set up a match to cover that and that
means we still have one hidden around
here somewhere it looks like he's right
here and if I match these I'll be able
to see yep he's on there he moved up got
a little bit lucky there and you know
that's that's the thing so this is a
really easy one but on the more
complicated levels you know you really
want to pay attention to where they go
and sort of plan ahead you know if you
you know you have to you know kind of
think about where they're gonna end up
this will end the level right now
because this will turn into a fish and
eat this piece of ice some other things
to keep in mind there just like there's
the fish don't necessarily go where they
are they just go after ice so if I you
know if I shot off one of these fish it
could go to any one of these it wasn't
necessarily help it's not like a honey
level you know for instance and soda
where you know the fish go right to the
Bears and so I'm gonna end this and then
we'll load up another one and talk a
little more strategy
puffers just just for how the games
advanced publicly and there was you know
they they've definitely improved the way
that they look and the way that they
kind of moved but it's a pretty
interesting pretty interesting level
type just because like I said it's a
little bit it's similar to what you
already know with the bears but it's a
new twist and that they move around so
well that wasn't like I said an easy
board with a little bit of ice so we'll
go ahead and skip ahead to one that's a
little more complicated and just talk
about some general strategy and then
I'll end the video and you guys can go
try to catch some puffers of your own so
you can see here this is a much bigger
board and it has double layers and some
which we can't see through and it also
has this hole in the middle which makes
it a little bit harder to make special
candies so we're gonna have to do the
same basic strategy I think I see one
here yeah you can see his hat underneath
there now he won't move until until we
actually exposed part so I'm gonna kind
of try to like cut off his escape route
a little bit and while I'm doing that I
will also be looking for the other one
cuz I don't know where it's at
alright so it's there now it's over here
and moved over here so cut in this
connection would be good now it can't
move to that side of the board because
you don't think you can go around
corners so either way if we can cut off
this middle part
now they're both up at the top together
so that's good so we just want to kind
of contain them and then go ahead and
free them once the once we can get the
right matches together this is kind of
like a not it's not who knows where
that's gonna go yeah well go ahead and
do that since he doesn't really have
anywhere to go
and that's just basically it I don't
wanna make this a really long video
because it's a pretty basic thing but
you know the hopefully those tips will
help you out a bit always pay attention
to where the puffers go always think
about their escape route where they can
go and then just make your matches over
top and clear them out and you shouldn't
have too much trouble with it there are
other levels that have buffalos I'll
make a separate video for that in a
little bit those are when you play
against cupcake Carl
he's like the counterpart of the Queen
where you have to collect more puffers
than he does rather than spreading the
jelly like you do against the clean so
I'll be looking forward to seeing you in
that video make sure you like the video
if you found it helpful subscribe to my
channel so you can get more how to play
videos and all the latest candy crush
jelly level videos as soon as they come
out I'll see you soon thanks